hagamos más ejemplos de cómo hallar el
dominio de una función digamos que
tenemos la función por ejemplo gx igual
a 1 dividido entre la raíz cuadrada de 6
menos el valor absoluto de x muy bien
esta es nuestra función g y te invito a
que por tu propia cuenta trates de
descubrir cuál es el dominio de esta
función verdad es decir el conjunto de
valores de entrada x donde esta función
está definida muy bien y ahora vamos a
hacerlo por nuestra propia digamos vamos
a hacerlo juntos más bien por ejemplo
una forma equivalente de decir cuál es
el dominio de esta función es determinar
donde no está definida la función verdad
por ejemplo si el denominador de esta
expresión es igual a 0 no está definida
verdad no podemos dividir ningún número
entre 0 o bien por ejemplo si lo que
está dentro de esta raíz cuadrada es
negativa verdad porque no podemos sacar
raíz
es cuadradas de números negativos así
que por ejemplo en realidad tendríamos
que esto que tenemos dentro de la raíz
no está definido si es cero o si es
negativo
negativo verdad es otra forma de pensar
el dominio de la función entonces g está
definida está definida
si solos y que de hecho lo podemos
escribir así como ese con doble y esto
representa sí solos y sí solos y 6 - el
valor absoluto de x es estrictamente
mayor que 0 verdad no puede ser 0 porque
estaríamos dividiendo entre 0 pero
tampoco puede ser negativo porque está
dentro de una raíz así que esto que como
podríamos expresar esto por ejemplo si
sumamos de ambos lados el valor absoluto
de x verdad ambos lados de esta
desigualdad bueno del lado izquierdo se
cancelan y sólo nos queda 6 mayor que el
valor absoluto de x o si lo vemos al
revés tendríamos valor absoluto de x
menor que 6 y esto es exactamente
equivalente a que x sea más chico que 6
pero más grande que menos 6 verdad si la
magnitud de x es menor que 6 es lo que
tenemos aquí es lo mismo que si x se
encuentra entre menos
y 6 muy bien entonces aquí tenemos de
forma digamos no tan clara definida
el dominio definido el dominio de de la
función g verdad podríamos incluso
escribirlo de esta forma que el dominio
es el conjunto de x que son números
reales verdad son elementos del conjunto
de números reales tales que x se
encuentra entre menos 6 y 6 verdad es
mayor que menos 6 y menor que 6 ok ahora
hagamos otro ejemplo que sea un poco más
peliagudo
veamos vamos a construir la siguiente
función digamos ahora vamos a llamarle
hdx vamos a considerar hdx una función
que esté definida por partes digamos que
la primera parte sea algo así como x +
/ / x + 10 que multiplica a x menos 9
que multiplica a x menos 5 digamos y que
esto esté definido para x distintos de 5
muy bien y digamos que cuando x valga 5
toma el valor de pi ok entonces te
invitó nuevamente a que hagas una pausa
y que pienses cuál es el dominio de esta
función
y entonces vamos a hacerlo todos juntos
digamos en realidad el único detalle es
cuando en la parte de arriba tenemos que
dividir en 3 entre 0 verdad es decir
cuando esta expresión de abajo toma el
valor 0 entonces podríamos incluso
escribirlo así para cuando vamos a
tratar de descubrir cuando estamos
dividiendo entre 0 digamos y hay que
escribir así en la parte de arriba en la
parte de arriba porque en la parte de
abajo no hay ningún problema verdad solo
tomo un valor constante entonces cuando
dividimos entre 0 sería cuando x es
igual a por ejemplo cuando es igual a an
a 9 por ejemplo si nos fijamos en esta
parte cuando x es igual a 9 estaríamos
dividiendo entre 0 también estaríamos
dividiendo en 30 cuando x tome el valor
de menos 10 verdad x igual a menos 10
hace que por este factor dividamos entre
o bien uno podría pensar que también
cuando x es igual a 5 estaríamos
dividiendo entre 0 sin embargo hay que
considerar esto estamos solo en la parte
de arriba y para qué valores está
definida la parte de arriba justamente
cuando x es distinto de 5 es decir este
no es un caso en el que podamos contar
porque cuando x es 5 toma otro valor
entonces este no es ningún problema para
la parte de arriba muy bien entonces
solo estos valores tendríamos
sólo estos dos valores nos causarían
problemas en la parte de arriba ahora ya
casi acabamos verdad pero a lo mejor
alguno de ustedes verán por ejemplo que
no podríamos cancelar este factor oops
creo que lo dejé negro que no podríamos
cancelar este factor con este otro para
simplificarlo y casi tendría razón sin
embargo sería una función distinta
verdad porque si tú cancelas el factor x
más 10 tanto arriba como abajo estarías
quitando el problema de x igual a menos
10 verdad esta función no está definida
en x igual a menos 10 pero si lo
cancelas si estaría definida en x igual
a menos 10 así que esencialmente
tendrías una función distinta que ahora
sí estaría definida en x igual a menos
10 así que en resumen lo que tenemos es
que el dominio de esta función lo
podemos escribir como el conjunto de
números reales
números reales tales que x no es 9 y x
no es menos 10 verdad fuera de estos
valores la función si está definida por
ejemplo cuando vale 5 cuando x es igual
a 5 es más podríamos escribirlo cuando x
es igual a 5
al evaluar h en 5 tenemos el valor de pi
incluso si en la parte de arriba no está
definido pero no hay problema porque ahí
no estamos considerando esta regla
estamos considerando la de abajo